welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid I got into an argument with this
guy over in my centripetal force video
before I realized he was only there to
argue not to learn he will go nameless
because I don't want him getting any
more attention but here's the gist of
the argument if you're on a spinning
merry-go-round holding a ball at its
edge what happens when you let go of the
ball he was insistent the ball will go
straight away from the center common
answer yes is it correct
no before you let go of the ball it's
moving with the merry-go-round this way
so that's the way it's going to move
when you let go needless to say he was
not happy with this answer some people
just don't like having their view of
reality questioned you don't have to
take my word for it though this seems
simple enough to test in the real world
usually this phenomenon is shown in a
classroom using a ball on a string but
this is not a classroom this is the
science Asylum rule number four go big
or go home let's go back to the
merry-go-round wait one spaceship clone
it's time for the Ella port
uh but it didn't look like that when I
was on the merry-go-round that's true
but remember rotating perspectives are
weird let's take another look at that
diagram when you let go of that ball you
keep spinning with the merry-go-round so
you don't measure motion relative to the
ground you measure it relative to you
and that tends to point away from you
it's an illusion created by the rotating
frame on top of that once the ball
appears to be moving away from you the
Coriolis effect comes into play and the
ball veers to one side and we're gonna
prove it ok but I'm already a little
sick from last time I don't care just do
it
so when did you learn that spinning
makes you sick please share in the
comments and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy